[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
alec baldwin speaks out on camera for
the first time since the fatal rust
movie shooting lawn crimes angenette
levy reports live about what the actor
had to say and entering day 10 of jury
selection in georgia for the trial and
the death of a mod arbory brian
buckmeyer is live on the ground with the
latest for this high profile case plus
jury selection begins in wisconsin for
the accused kenosha shooter kyle
rittenhouse more on what to expect from
the trial that is soon to come and later
try to calm down
an accused murderer takes the stand in
his second murder trial more inside the
heated florida courtroom coming up on
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome to law and crime daily i'm
alison hall in for brian buckmeyer who's
covering the death of the ahmad arbory
trial co-host terry austin is also with
me for the first time alec baldwin is
talking about the shooting on the set of
the movie rust that killed a
cinematographer lawn crime's angenette
levy is here with what baldwin and the
film's armorer are saying anjanet
allison alec baldwin and his wife
hilarious pulled over on the side of a
road in vermont to speak with a reporter
who was following them baldwin told
backgrid that cinematographer helena
hutchins was his friend
baldwin seen here in much happier times
told backgrid over the weekend that him
shooting and killing cinematographer
helena hutchins was a quote one in a
trillion event baldwin was rehearsing a
cross draw last month on the set of rust
when he pointed the gun at the camera
and fired killing hutchins and wounding
director joel souza baldwin told
backgrid the crew was a well-oiled
machine and then this happened he also
said of hutchinson's husband he is in
shock he has a nine-year-old son we are
in constant contact with him because we
are very worried about his family and
his kid baldwin said he was ordered by
the santa fe county sheriff's office to
not discuss the incident questions have
been raised about the film's armorer
hannah gutierrez reid and her level of
experience and assistant director dave
halls who handed the gun to baldwin and
told him it was safe gutierrez reads
attorneys issued a statement saying she
has no idea how live ammunition made it
on the set they went on to say quote
hannah and the prop master gained
control over the guns and she never
witnessed anyone shoot live rounds with
these guns and nor would she permit that
hannah was hired on two positions on
this film which made it extremely
difficult to focus on her job as an
armorer meanwhile baldwin's wife hilaria
posted this photo on instagram with the
caption i love you and i'm here
and the investigation into this shooting
is ongoing santa fe county sheriff says
it's way too early to determine whether
or not charges will be filed against
anyone and he cautioned against people
calling this an accident he says this is
a criminal investigation allison
thank you ann jeannette we're joined now
by co-host terry austin and criminal
offense defense attorney suanne robinson
suanne let's start with you in last
week's press conference the santa fe
district attorney told reporters charges
are still on the table for anyone
involved in the incident what is the
likelihood we will see criminal charges
here especially for baldwin himself
it's really
you know i don't think it's likely that
alec baldwin will
face criminal charges but again it
depends on what's revealed in this
investigation in terms of how live
rounds got on the set was there someone
else that brought the live rounds and
what exactly happened i mean the more we
get into the more information we get out
the more we can kind of gauge what's the
likelihood of criminal charges but i
certainly think there's going to be
something done with respect to the armor
with respect to the 80
for sure but um alec at this time you
know based on the story that he said and
what happened what we know about what
happened so far it would be extremely
unlikely
and terry baldwin made several claims
during his statement to the press on
saturday could any of those statements
impact potential litigation
i think it's not going to impact the
criminal case but i think it could have
some impact on a potential civil case if
one is brought for either wrongful death
or some negligence and i think that his
comment that these things happen at
their incidental incidents and we had a
very well oiled crew we know already
based on some of the reports that things
were not running that well and so it
seems as though this was protecting
himself and protecting him from exposure
as a producer so very gratuitous
and and janette can you tell us about
the new information that just came out
about those moments leading up to the
shooting
well allison the la times reported on
monday that they had spoken with a
number of people who were on the set
they also reviewed text messages and
they recalled to the la times how alec
baldwin was rehearsing that scene and he
pulled the gun out of his holster and
said so i guess i'm going to take this
out pull it and go bang that is when the
gun went off he pointed it toward the
camera as we've been reporting hutchins
then fell backwards according to the la
times report and said no that was no
good that was no good at all she later
died that evening allison
thank you so much anjanet and to all of
you for your thoughts on this in other
top legal news celebrity rapper fetty
wapp pleads not guilty to charges of
trafficking on friday fetty wap whose
legal name is willie jr maxwell ii was
arrested thursday night by the fbi on
federal drug charges just before he was
scheduled to appear at a concert in long
island the grammy-nominated star was
arraigned with five of his co-defendants
officials said that in 2019 the group
distributed more than 100 kilograms of
cocaine heroin fentanyl and crack from
long island to new jersey prosecutors
described it as a quote multi-million
dollar bi-coastal drug distribution
organization if convicted the minimum
sentence would be 10 years in prison the
maximum could send him to prison for
life
still ahead on long crime daily the
accused kenosha shooter is about to
stand trial but not before the jury is
seated more on jury selection out of
wisconsin
but first day 10 of jury selection in
the trial for the death of a mod arbory
our very own brian buckmeyer is live
with the latest out of georgia
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily we
look now to georgia where we continue on
to day 10 of jury selection in the trial
for the death of a mod arbory gregory
and travis mcmichael and william roddy
bryan face charges of malice murder
felony murder and aggravated assault in
the shooting of the 25 year old jogger
in february 2020 prosecutors say father
and son duo gregory and travis
mcmichaels tailed arbory in a pickup
truck as he was out for a run near his
home in georgia travis mcmichael opened
fire and killed arbory claiming
self-defense brian followed along in his
own vehicle recording the incident on
his phone jury selection continues as
the court tries to reach the magic
number of 64 in which they will
eventually choose the final jurors for
the case
live on the ground in georgia is our
very own brian buckmeyer who is bringing
us the latest in today's jury selection
brian what are the takeaways from the
start of week three of jury selection
so allison one of the big points was
that we started off at least we thought
we started off with 55 jurors but from
friday the judge had said that there was
one juror who had some child care issues
that still left him with some sort of
reservation or pause this morning he
cleared that up by disqualifying that
juror and so now we are down to 54. 17
jurors came in so we were hoping for 10
more but a number of them were
disqualified one juror was disqualified
because of a felony record and she
didn't restore her rights to vote
another was disqualified because she was
over the age of 70 and didn't want to
serve one of the statutory provisions
here in georgia and wonder is
disqualified because of a fixed opinion
that the mcmichaels and brian should be
acquitted now a court will continue on
election day as well as veterans day but
at this point is just a numbers game
trying to get to 64 jurors as only a
handful make it as qualified jurors each
day
and brian we've already seen a pretty
lengthy jury selection in this case is
there any indication a jury could be
chosen early this week
i think that is the hope and the prayer
because what we're seeing allison as i
said 54 jurors today so we just need 10
more i don't think we're going to get
more than five or six today they're
actually still questioning jurors
later into the night but hopefully by
wednesday afternoon we may have a panel
where we start those peremptory
challenges
and brian once we move on from jury
selection eventually how will the trial
portion of this case go being that we
have three defendants here
so it's really just everything times
three we're expecting the further to be
opening statements in this county or the
state of georgia you'll see the
prosecution go first and then the
defense attorneys each one of them
having three opening statements and the
prosecution gonna get off to having a
final opening statement after that might
i expect that to happen then each and
every witness that gets called by the
prosecution the defense would have an
opportunity to cross-examine them but
they seem to be working together
somewhat to streamline their questioning
of jurors at least hopefully do the same
thing for cross-examination
right thank you brian well we'll
definitely check back in with you
tomorrow to see when that trial has a
full jury
coming up on law and crime daily
markeith loyd takes the stand in his own
murder trial to explain why he opened
fire at a police officer
plus jury selection is underway in
wisconsin for the accused kenosha
shooter kyle rittenhouse what you can
expect from the trial starting later
this week
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily jury
selection begins in the case of
wisconsin versus kyle rittenhouse the
accused kenosha shooter 18-year-old
rittenhouse faces multiple charges
including first-degree reckless homicide
intentional homicide and attempted
homicide the charges stem from the 2020
kenosha riots following the shooting of
jacob blake a black man who was shot by
a white police officer prosecutors say a
then 17-year-old written house drove to
kenosha from illinois and shot three
people during the protests joseph
rosenbaum and anthony huber were shot
and killed gage grot reutz was injured
rittenhouse could face a life sentence
without parole if convicted wisconsin
does not have the death penalty he has
pled not guilty to the crimes
150 potential jurors were summoned in
this case 80 were called to the kenosha
county courthouse on monday with a final
goal of 20 to be chosen
judge bruce schroeder told the potential
jurors the trial is expected to last
about two weeks
terry the judge ruled that the
individuals who were shot could not be
called victims but could be called
rioters or looters what are your
thoughts on that ruling
here's what i think allison i agree with
the prosecution i think it's a double
standard being used here judge schroeder
ruled that the three men who were shot
could be called rioters looters or
arsonists and when you do that you're
putting in the jury's mind that kyle
rittenhouse had a right to shoot and to
defend himself that's exactly what the
defense wants to do but saying that the
people who were shot can't be called
victims definitely is putting the
prosecution at a disadvantage and the
prosecutor did argue that the judge
didn't go for it so at the end of the
day we're going to see that if the
evidence supports it they can call these
people writers and looters
and suanne as we mentioned the state of
wisconsin does not have the death
penalty had this case happened in
rittenhouse's home state of illinois we
could have seen a death penalty if
convicted what sort of alternative could
we expect to see in wisconsin if
rittenhouse is found guilty
i think if he's found guilty you know on
the highest charge then obviously it's
life without parole um you know
if schroeder is the sentencing judge who
knows because he's made a couple bad
calls especially with this victim
not allowing victim
the decedents to be called victims but
permitting them to be called looters and
writers because even in his explanation
he said he does he thinks victim is a
loaded word he thinks of a person who's
a victim has to be proven it has to be
demonstrated he said he's in a very
small minority of judges who feel this
way but then on the other hand he said
it's fine for them to be called looters
and arsonists and writers when that
hasn't been proven either so i i do
agree that you know he he's he's made a
bad call on that for sure and we it
would remain to be seen how he would
handle sentencing
thank you sue and thank you terry and on
capitol hill the supreme court heard
nearly three hours worth of arguments
relating to the texas law that prevents
abortions six weeks into pregnancy the
court declined to block this contentious
law in a close five to four decision
back in early september the law includes
no exceptions for pregnancies resulting
from rape or incest and has caused a
significant increase of people leaving
the state to look for abortions
elsewhere the law bars state officials
from enforcing it therefore it allows
for private citizens to take legal
action against anyone who performs the
procedure or quote aids and abets it the
supreme court heard arguments on monday
from abortion providers and the biden
administration to challenge the court's
previous ruling the biden administration
argued that the federal government
should be able to sue to stop the law
from being enforced texas's solicitor
general argued that the federal
government and abortion providers do not
have the legal grounds to sue the state
and federal court mark hiron an attorney
for the abortion providers argued that
the texas law created a chilling effect
by providing bounties to private
citizens to enforce it
right now there is no deadline for the
justices to act on the arguments heard
monday
when we come back the defendant takes
the stand in florida
can this previously convicted murderer
escape charges this time with his own
testimony more on what markeith loyd had
to say to the jury next
[Music]
welcome back convicted murderer robert
durst is indicted in new york for the
1982 murder of his first wife this after
he has transferred to state prison in
california after being hospitalized with
covid19 the real estate airs transfer
comes two weeks after being sentenced to
life in prison for the december 2000
murder of his best friend susan berman
last month durst was put on a ventilator
and moved from the los angeles jail
system to a health care facility in
northern california where inmates with
the most severe and long-term medical
needs are treated durst has since been
transferred back to the state prison
all of this was happening amidst
arguments in new york where prosecutors
were presenting evidence to a grand jury
for the case of durst's missing wife
kathy who disappeared in 1982
and whose body has yet to be found kathy
was declared legally dead in 2017. on
monday afternoon durst was officially
indicted for the murder of kathy durst
and the defense rests in florida in
markeith loyd's second murder trial for
the death of lieutenant debra clayton
clayton was gunned down by the defendant
as she attempted to arrest him for the
murder of his ex-girlfriend sade dixon
lloyd was charged and convicted of that
murder
in that case he avoided the death
penalty and was sentenced to life in
prison if convicted for this crime lloyd
could face the death penalty again the
defense rested its case in front of the
jury on monday morning but not after the
defendant took the stand in his own
defense the jury heard lloyd's testimony
on saturday morning where he spent
nearly three and a half hours on the
stand and maintained that he was afraid
for his life he told the courtroom his
version of events that led to the death
of deborah clayton
why didn't you run away
i just turned my back on she just tried
to shoot me in the back if i turn my
back on again well i'm going to get shot
in the back okay
and
during the shootout were you both
returning fire at each other yes
did you feel that your life was in
danger yes
did you believe that you had to return
fire to defend your life yes
she falls down when she fall down she
still continued she fired she's firing
at me from the ground
so even on the ground she had her gun
out yes she still was firing and she was
still firing yes okay
and so what is your purpose at that
point
i was trying to hit her vest
to knock her out
things got heated during cross
examination where the defendant was told
to calm down by prosecutors
any same person
any same person
no if i'm an officer and i got a lead
supposed to be murdered he's saying
he'll turn himself in if i had a news
retract a lie that the news told i'mma
had a news retractor alive when i know
it's a lie unless i'm responsible for
the lie so that's how i knew it was the
police doing it try to calm down
michelle i'm all gone
[Music]
so don't try to make it something it's
not mr ryan go ahead you can go ahead
suanne this is the second time markeith
lloyd took the stand to defend himself
was this a strong decision by the
defense do you think he was successful
in defending himself
successful in what would be the question
i think he was successful in getting on
the stand and getting through it without
being held in contempt he had the
opportunity to basically give a
presentation to the jury the jury that's
going to decide his fate the last time
he did that he was able to avoid the
death penalty so i think a success for
him here would be to avoid the death
penalty for the jurors to you know even
if he is convicted to see that
a human side of him see his opportunity
and
terry i want to move to you here on the
stand lloyd claimed that he had no
mental illness yet he tried to explain
why his lawyers are claiming otherwise
what do you make of that you know
it's just a defense really alison as far
as we're concerned and so you know we'll
see what happens the forensic
psychologists who got on did a good job
thank you so much to both of you and
thank you for joining us here on long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you